do you chase passion do you chase money
who's right a lot of motivational
speakers say never give up on your
dreams always chase your passion always
chase your dream actors actresses
athletes even presidents sometimes say
that but who the hell is right we're
gonna get to the bottom of it today okay
[Music]
so if this video gets you more clear
about your decision whether you ought to
chase passion or money i want you to
give me a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel having said that let's get right
into it so the way i see it is i see
money chasing money as a logic i see
chasing passion as emotion meaning left
brain logical right brain emotional now
when you hear the word emotion like i
want to chase passion what are people
really talking about what are we
passionate about is it art is it sports
is it travel is it animals is it movies
fitness hobbies
partying faith god philos i'm passionate
about my church i'm passionate about art
i'm passionate about sports what is it
you're passionate about to say i don't
want to chase money i just want to chase
passion because i've heard if you chase
passion money will follow it's not
always right i'm 42 years old i am in
love with baseball i love baseball do i
go chase being a major league baseball
player today because i'm so passionate
about it i think money is going to show
up maybe the dodgers are going to sign a
42 year old middle eastern man that
never played organized baseball because
i'm so passionate about it right oof i'm
going to make it to the major leagues
he's gonna buy my baseball card one day
from upper deck or prism and all this
other stuff that's kind of cool right
yeah but is that really something that
i'm capable of doing ray dalio once said
he said you can almost do anything but
not everything the sooner you know that
you can't do everything the sooner
you'll be able to not waste time chasing
stuff that maybe you're not gonna be
able to monetize right or be great at
now let's look at logic now watch this
logic is a little bit boring this is
exciting
this is a little bit boring if you think
about it so logic you got to be able to
learn how to reason with people critical
thinking wow that's sexy right
accountability who doesn't want to wake
up in the morning being accountable to
investors to a boss to a
to clients we love being held
accountable right or analytical or
strategy or numbers or sequencing of
facts this is boring but necessary this
is exciting but doesn't necessarily
provide results all the time so i want
you to think about it from this angle
think about the biggest decisions you're
going to make in your life right can we
say marriage is one of the biggest
decisions you'll ever make in your life
is that a fair assessment okay let's
just say you said yes
should your decision be made on emotion
and passion should your decision be made
on logic not necessarily money but logic
but let's think about this should it be
100 emotional i come home and you say
hey mom dad guess what what
i just met this girl i love her i've
never felt this way before i know
nothing about her past i know her
parents during best she's been a mess i
think she told me that her last 17
boyfriends never worked out but i think
i'm going to be the one because i'm
crazy about her what do you know about
her past not a lot is she crew or i
don't know that i just love her should
you marry purely on emotion or maybe
take your time a little bit how about
logic how about you date somebody and
say
you know mom i don't really like this
guy hey babe when you're around him does
he give you the butterflies like do you
get excited about not at all are you
attracted to him at all mom i think he's
ugly
babe why are you dating this guy
mom he's so loaded
he's got so much money he's so rich
you're just doing it based on logic you
think that's also the right way of doing
it depends on who you ask right so
there's got to be a balance the debate
becomes should the decision be sixty
percent emotion forty percent logic
should it be sixty percent less some
will tell you seventy percent of logic
because guess what if you get married to
somebody then you gotta make one of the
other decisions which is what kids
that's hard work raising kids nowadays
right career what industry should i be a
part of where you live should i live in
california should i live in new york
should i move because the regulation is
changing in my state i want to go to a
different place
education buying a home friendship all
of this
depends on the decision you make based
on your passion or logic now
a big part of the decisions we make if
you look at this graphic i try to do my
best to explain it to you
the younger we are from the day we're
born to say 80.
the younger we are pink represents
passion and emotion green represents
more logic right the younger we are we
only like to make decisions based on
passion and emotion we don't make the
best best decisions at some point in
your life after many breakups after you
realize we all pay taxes after you
realize
not you're not always going to be the
one chosen for promotion you're going to
be passed up on promotion sometime a guy
that's lazier just because they're
related to the mother of the business or
the ceo of the business is going to get
the promotion over you and that pisses
you off because you stayed up every
night till 10 o'clock and that schmuck
gets the promotion over you just because
his last name is johnson and yours is
not and you can never compete with that
kid then you start realizing saying
listen man this passion stuff i'm sorry
i work a lot harder than the other guy
what does he deserve it you start kind
of getting a little bit of this and
about 30 to 40 years old you sit there
and say maybe i need to start making
some logical decisions as well listen i
love this girl she's attractive she's
hot but i got to kind of start thinking
about is this the right thing the last
three relationships didn't work because
of that what should i do so
i'm not sitting here telling you this or
i'm not telling you this
i'm telling you to get this balance
right in what areas of your life do you
use emotion in what areas of your life
do you use logic for example
buying underwear how much emotion do i
need to buy an underwear like do i go i
go to costco i need some underwear do i
need to make an emotional connection
with that underwear to buy an underwear
no that's a hundred percent logical i'm
buying an underwear now if you're buying
lingerie does there need to be a little
bit of emotional connection to that
laundry because you know you kind of
need to look good at it but you know
i get it so laundry may be a little bit
different
socks are you going to turn somebody in
with socks i look at these socks oh my
gosh you look so sexy today it sucks
pure logic right
car you like it i kind of like it when i
sat in it the engine maybe a little bit
but you need to kind of balance this
part out by the way
long term you will win more the more you
pay attention to this now let's go back
to this i'm a pretty creative guy i'm a
pretty passionate guy i'm passionate
about a lot of weird things i like
baseball cards i just had a what do you
call it a car that just was delivered
right now to me it's a 1965
shelby cobra curcum it's a
aluminum silver i just drove it i can't
even tell you what it sounds like when i
turn on the engine like oh my gosh
right when i drove that car it was
ridiculous right but i'm in an insurance
industry very logical
compliance actuaries underwriting table
a table b table c table d
pouring to some people right but we put
on a conventional last week i just got
back two days ago we filled out the mgm
grand arena during delta during cove
during shutdown during all this mess and
we had over ten thousand people at this
even with nicki jam was performing we
had you know what he called a sebastian
monoskalka i mean he was hilarious mario
lopez was the mc of the evening kim and
i were co-emceeing i had mike tyson i
had frederick da silva there people were
crying laughing cracking up having a
blast because we learned how to combine
a logical industry with emotions because
this is still tied to emotions
if you can figure out a way to balance
those two you'll win at the highest
level few things i will tell you rather
than asking the question should i chase
passion or should i chase money i'll
give you a different perspective i like
to chase the right habits i want to
chase working with the person that i'm
going to sit in a boardroom and see how
they negotiate see how they address
conflicts see how they address issues i
want to chase being part of an
organizational company with a big vision
that seems almost impossible where they
have an opposition and people say you
cannot do it and i'm in that room with
these people and seeing how all of a
sudden oh my gosh i can bring value to
this area why i can bring value to this
area oh my gosh look how we overcame
this how do we overcame that one time
when we almost ran out of money and then
you when in that process of doing the
impossible with a group you learn how to
become a better leader you're on how to
move people better you realize you're
tougher than you actually thought you
were you were able to handle things in
ways maybe you never thought you could
handle then you pick up all these
incredible habits at that point you can
choose to continue with that
organization but what you definitely did
do is you increase your market share
and you learn how to work with different
passionate people that bring different
things to the table when you make money
you can always fund your passion i love
making movies i'm gonna make movies i
love art i'm gonna buy a lot of
ridiculous art i love baseball cards
i've bought many and i plan on buying a
lot more i am passionate about all of
this stuff i will never stop funding
this
but it's sequencing understanding what
percentage needs to be logic
understanding what percentage needs to
be emotion hopefully that helped yet if
you took a lot away from this video
smash thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel got a video i want you to watch
i did a video years ago i think maybe
six years ago five years ago titled how
to double your money if you've never
watched that video before how to double
your money click over here to watch that
video that's probably going to lead you
to another video called 20 rules of
money but start with this first then go
watch 20 rules of money take care
everybody bye
[Music]